okay play another random sub ooh playing
bdg subscriber also subscriber gift here
let's play well I'm not black so I'm not
gonna play a hippo I'll try and play a
gambit French what can i play oh there's
there's interesting gambit against the
French b3 b3 d5 Bishop d2 or Bishop
should be too
I forget what we call this but it's
interesting the idea is after 964 and
I'll likely win back the pawn and I'll
play queenie tune castle I remember
seeing this used as like a surprise
opening and some high-level events I
don't think it's a bad opening it's hard
for black to like be prepared for this
it's pretty uh pretty rare
ooh oh no no ratings first game maybe he
plays casual but okay so no information
about my opponents level in so far
blocks playing very reasonably maybe
after the game I can kind of gauge and
give an estimate of what what rating the
play is like is there a lot of beef
between serious chess players I mean
some players are vegetarian or vegan so
they stay away from beef I think that
vine would included G tag welcome back
thanks for the ten bits
I'd say generally like chess community
is pretty pretty nice but then again
like I don't know relationships between
like all the top players but everyone
I've interacted with has been like has
been very nice especially at the top
level - whoa bow ties hmm yeah well we
turned Komodo into beef and then we have
a feast Thanks Alexandra boat s for
subbing always brings back good memories
of Komodo beef a5 scares me because the
attack is coming I could play I could
just ignore it
hmm pretend it doesn't exist I think oh
I take a pawn like f3 you play played e3
all these are random options let's play
g3 I want to make the rook happy and the
bishop happy simultaneously always play
king b1 but always play Bishop f1 writes
I always play off three
all I could do a boat s gambit next
opportunity but it has to be reasonable
even though by definition it's
unreasonable I'll try and find a moment
to do it
okay pieces are now happy Wow see five
so like I'm pretty much completed with
developments and play night yeah it's
just develop still looking for
opportunities to like give away the
Queen hmm play complete g5 let's play g5
yeah g5 it's got some emailed action how
much will my opponents rating goes up go
up
if-if-if bdg wins there we go up zero
points also go down zero points
regardless cuz this is casual I'm pretty
sure there's like I'm there's a max or
min number of points you can gain I
guess max number of points you can gain
for a while
a4
hmm
this position actually looks very fun
I'm gonna play f4 going for f5 and we'll
see what happens
Wow night before I could sack the rook
I'm not sagging my queen not pulling a
boat Ted's gambit but I'm sacking
probably gonna end up sacking a lot take
on e6 I take on d4 whew taking on d4
let's do it and then this move or what
else there's also rook t1 now let's do
this
okay let's take a pawn so I'm only down
a rook for a bishop that's not bad King
sigh castling well it's retreats the
retrieving attacking move
I did have Bishop c6 but I like this
Bishop if I were to take pawn takes
Queen takes ours Bishop d7 defending the
rook
normally when you're down material you
don't want to trade unless there's a
good reason for it
Queen c7 attacking a pawn I think I'll
play I'll play this move just defending
I think the goal is to play this in this
get the Bishop Hill hmm let's start with
ooh hu Falls there's a lot of things to
be concerned about
[Music]
taggi thanks for the long time no bits
bits what do I do
I'm scared of this move okay I have an
idea I'm gonna play this move and if
Knight before I check and if King f8
Bishop a3 have to be resourceful
have you seen John's feel mainstream not
recently me a while ago I know he was
doing commentary on the chests for some
top level tournaments chess equals math
yeah math basically equals everything
right
or equals some things and probably have
to do the math on that
there's a point in time I really enjoyed
math but it didn't it's in full elast
Bishop h7 okay let's have some fun
I'll throw in the check I'll probably
take the pawn next as if king expecting
King f8 and I want to play this but then
there's b4 so I'll take the pawn first
those free pawn why not and then going
for this
Wow yes there's still some opportunity
to sacrifice a queen it's looking like a
very right position for botas gambit
what to do I'll save the Queen a little
bit longer oh dear
Oh botas gaba is so close to working
here it's insane
I can't resist if it doesn't work it's
all boat has his faults this looks like
too much fun at least temporary fun
can't believe I'm doing this
I just I gave away a queen for two pawns
but I have a nice night
some forking potential I rooks kind of
hanging okay that's a reasonable move I
have this move anything better let's
play this move first I mean the pieces I
do have they're on there controlling
some squares the rooks still kind of
attacked Wow oh my gosh am i my meeting
and to this maiden to this is made into
me chess will restart in nine minutes
okay plenty of time Knight b6 the King
has to go back double check mates double
check needs this is more beautiful than
double rainbow double check makes this
okay have to dedicate that it's a boat s
it's so beautiful
bow ties subdue like during this game
was some good omen
like the Komodo hoof thanks John Davis
and coolest blue wasn't nasty it's very
nasty but I don't want to wash my hands
like this is it's what chess is all
about YouTube worthy double windows yeah
for for people watching in the future on
YouTube what do I call this video
boat s can that leads to double check
mate yeah this photos you two should
play